Entschuldige… Darth… ich mal vorbei?
Tach zusammen, Jack Pop hier.
Die Geburtsstunde von Darth Vader ist das, was für normale Menschen der sichere Tod gewesen wäre.
Denn nachdem Anakin Skywalker im Kampf gegen Count Dooku schon eine Hand verloren hat,
kostet ihn das Duell auf Mustafar gegen Obi-WanKenobi dann auch noch die andere Hand
und beide Beine. Und als ob das nicht schon schlimm genug wäre, fällt er am Ende auch noch in Lava.
Retten kann ihn nur noch ein Hightech-Anzug,vollgepackt mit lebenserhaltenden Geräten.
Und genau den nehmen wir heute mal für Euch auseinander und schauen, was der alles kann.
Lasst uns mal mit dem Ikonischsten beginnen,
mit dem Helm. Der besteht eigentlich aus drei Teilen. Der hat einen verstärkten Kragen,
diese schwarze Gesichtsmaske und den
eigentlichen Helm, den man von oben drauf setzt.
Und was der alles draufhat, kannuns keiner besser erklären als
Luke vom Kanal Nerdfactory. Luke, mega cool, dass Du dabei bist.
Hey Jack! Ja, genau so ist es. Der Helm ist quasi ein kleines
Meisterwerk der Technik. Da drin stecken: ein implantierter Lautsprecher mit Sprachprozessor,
der Vaders beschädigte Stimmbänder ersetzt. Außerdem enthält er verschiedene Umweltsensoren,
die auf Strahlungen und zum Beispiel Biosignaturen reagieren und die Linsen im Heim sind
Head-up-Displays. Sie können sowohl infraroteals auch ultraviolette Strahlen darstellen,
verdunkeln bei Notwendigkeit und er kann
in voller Dunkelheit auch perfekt sehen.
Aber die Frage ist, was es von der ganzen Technik,
die da drinsteckt, in der realen Welt
schon gibt. Und um das zu beantworten,
brauchen wir die Weisheit von einem, der beides ist. Star Wars-Fan und Wissenschaftler.
Hubert Zitt ist Professor für Technische
Informatik an der Hochschule Kaiserslautern
und so ein krasser Star Wars-Fan, dass er die Sternwarte dort in einen
gigantischen R2D2 verwandelt hat… Was
sogar Luke Skywalker richtig cool fand.
Über Science-Fiction-Technik hält der ganze Vorlesungen;
bei den Star Wars-Filmen ist er ganz klar Team Originaltrilogie.
Herr Zitt, herzlich willkommen.Schön, dass Sie da sind!
Ja, es ist gut, dabei zu sein.
Der Helm von Darth Vader hat Umweltsensoren und Luke hat unserzählt,
dass man damit Strahlung
detektieren kann oder Biosignaturen,
also man kann damit Leben erkennen. Solche Sensoren gibt es doch heute schon, oder?
Ja, die gibt es und Darth Vader hat solche
Sensoren sicherlich auch in seinem Anzug
integriert. Forscher in den USA haben einenChip entwickelt, damit kann man Biosignaturen
auf große Entfernungen detektieren und inVerbindung mit einem Teleskop könnte Darth Vader
sogar auf erdähnlichen Planeten einen Stützpunkt der Rebellen ausfindig machen.
Na vielleicht bekommt er dann Hinweis- oder Warnmeldungen angezeigt,
in diesen Head-up-Displays, die daverbaut sind. Und auch die gibt esschon,
zum Beispiel bei großen Flugzeugenwie der Boeing 787. Die hat so ein System.
Ja, Head-up-Displays sind wirklich einesehr coole Sache. Die gibt es auf der
Erde übrigens schon seit 1940er-Jahren. Ursprünglich entwickelt für Kampfjets,
werden die heute auch in der zivilen Luftfahrt und auch im Automobilbereich,
also bei teuren Autos, eingesetzt. Dann sieht derFahrer in der Windschutzscheibe Informationen,
zum Beispiel wie schnell er gerade fährtoder auch Informationen vom Navigationsgerät.
Und wenn man das dann noch mit Augmented Realitykombiniert, dass der Fahrer dann auch noch den
Abstand zum Vordermann berechnet und angezeigtbekommt, dann wird die Sache natürlich super cool.
Und Darth Vader kann damit ja noch viel mehr,
als sich die reinen Messwerte anzeigenlassen. Also diese Displays geben ihm eine
komplett erweiterte Sicht. Also er kannin kompletter Dunkelheit perfekt sehen.
Mit Infrarotsensoren, das sind ja die, die ja
dann auch in Nachtsichtgeräten eingebaut sind,
kann er Lebensformen bei völliger Dunkelheitsehen. So wie wir das heute auch in Autos
integriert haben. Wenn zum Beispiel einTier im Dunkeln auf die Straße läuft,
dann können wir das sehen, ohne dassdas Tier bereits beleuchtet ist.
Der UV Bereich liegt nun zwischen dem sichtbaren
Licht und dem Röntgenbereich. Und wenn dieFrequenz des Lichts nur hoch genug ist,
dann kann Darth Vader so etwas wiedie Compton-Rückstreutechnik anwenden.
Diese Technologie wird zum Beispiel bei
Nacktscannern am Flughafen eingesetzt.
Mit dieser Technologie kann Darth Vader bei seinem Gegenübererkennen, ob er vielleicht einen Blaster,
ein Lichtschwert oder sogar einen Thermal Detonatorunter seiner Haube oder seiner Rüstung versteckt.
Das heißt, Darth Vader kann mit diesem fancyDisplay viel besser sehen, als jeder normaleMensch.
Aber gleichzeitig kriegt er auchnoch alles, was um ihn herum passiert,
angezeigt. Und diese Technikgibt es tatsächlich heute schon.
Super markant ist natürlich auchDarth Vaders Stimme.
(„I am your father.“)
Und solche Stimmprothesen gibt es auch schon in der realen Welt.
(„Danke, ich rauche nicht mehr.“)
Da ist man heute aber schon ein ganzes
Stück weiter. An der Technischen Uni Graz
gibt es zum Beispiel das „Human EVoice“.Da haben Forschende ein Gerät entwickelt,
das Menschen ihren natürlichenStimmklang zurückgeben soll. Das ist
vor allen Dingen für Frauen interessant, weil dieStimmprothese, die bislang auf dem Markt waren,
er sehr tief und sehr männlich geklungenhaben. Aber okay, wenn wir ehrlich sind,
dann wäre Darth Vader auch nur halb sofurchteinflößend, wenn er halt nicht so…
(Filmzitat mit tiefer Männerstimme)
sondern so klingen würde:
(Filmzitat mit höherer Stimme)
Fazit bis hierher: der Helm von Darth Vaderist technisch schon durchaus realistischdargestellt.
Aber wenn Ihr jetzt denkt - „Geil, dann will ich so ein Ding unbedingthaben" -
kleiner Fun Fact am Rande. Die Maskeist mit Nadeln an seinem Kopf festgemacht,
die bis in sein Gehirn ragen, um da neuronaleSignale abzufangen. Stelle ich mir persönlich
jetzt nicht so super angenehm vor. Aber die Ideedahinter, eine Computer-Gehirn-Schnittstelle,
ist wieder durchaus realistisch. Das habenwir sogar schon einmal durchgesprochen,
nämlich in unserer Matrix-Folge. Und die verlinke ich Euch hier oben.
Wir haben vorhin schon darüber gesprochen, was fürschlimme Verletzungen Anakin Skywalker erlitten
hat. Dem fehlen alle Gliedmaßen. Der bekommtdann also mechanische Beine und Hände dran
operiert. Aber das reicht halt noch lange nichtaus. Und genau da kommt dann der Anzug ins Spiel,
der soll die körperlichen Folgenvon diesen ganzen Verletzungen und
Verbrennungen ausgleichen. Aber was genau macht er Anzug da jetzt, Luke?
Ja, am krassesten ist eigentlich, dass DarthVaders Lunge durch die Verbrennungen und giftigen
Dämpfe auf Mustafar extrem beschädigt ist. DerAnzug enthält deshalb ein Ventilationssystem,
das Luft direkt in die Lunge pumpt. Dieses System arbeitet ununterbrochen, was dazu führt,
dass er auch während des Sprechens aus- undeinatmen kann. Außerdem braucht Darth Vader
eine Art Herzschrittmacher und auch seineErnährung läuft über einen sehr direkten
Zugang in seinen Verdauungssystem. Also keine leckeren Sachen für ihn.
Spätestens jetzt wird klar, ohne diesen
Anzug ginge bei Darth Vader überhauptnichts.
Die Frage ist halt, ob das plausibel ist?
Klar, Maschinen, die Menschenkontrolliert beatmen gibt es schon,
nämlich in der Intensivmedizin,und es gibt auch solche Geräte,
die die Atmung lediglich unterstützen.Die erzeugen zum Beispiel einen Überdruck,
um beim Einatmen zu helfen und einen Unterdruckum das Ausatmen zu erleichtern. Das wäre dann
übrigens auch eine super Erklärung, für diesetypischen Atemgeräusche, die Darth Vader macht.
Und so ähnlich ist es auch mit seiner
Ernährungssonde. Auch die gibt es im realen Leben,
vor allem für Patientinnen und Patienten,
die langfristig nicht mehr schlucken können,
beispielsweise aufgrund von einer Tumorerkrankung. Die bekommen dann eine Sonde in den Magen,
über die sie dann Flüssigkeit, Nahrung, aber auch Medikamente aufnehmen können. Das Ding ist,
das alles muss ja irgendwo herkommen und in derRealität sind das solche Beutel hier.
Aber ich kann mir beim besten Willen nicht vorstellen, dasssich Darth Vader so ernährt. Oder, Professor Zitt?
Ja, ich kann mir auch nicht vorstellen, dass
Darth Vader immer mit einer Magensonde und einem
Urinbeutel rumläuft. Also ich stelle mirdas eher so vor, wie das zum Beispiel auf
der Raumstation gehandhabt wird. Da gibtes ein System, das nennt sich Melissa,
das recycelt praktisch alles und stellt neueNahrung her. Es ist sozusagen ein autonomesÖkosystem.
Und in einer Galaxis, weit weitentfernt, könnte es auch möglich sein, dass man so
ein System derart miniaturisieren kann, dass manes bei Darth Vader im Anzug integrieren könnte.
Was ich mich noch gefragt habe, wieviele Kalorien müsse denn der Anzug
täglich bereitstellen? Also was ist dennder Grundumsatz von Darth Vader, ohne diese
ganzen Lichtschwertkämpfe und schnellem Rennen.
Bei über zwei Metern und 120 Kilo Gewicht, mit demAnzug, ist der doch locker bei 2.500 Kilokalorien?
Das ist schwer zu sagen. Man kann einen solchen
mechanischen Anzug nicht mit einerbiologischen Lebensform vergleichen.
An dem Anzug sind ja Komponenten, die DarthVader das Leben erleichtern, also zumindest
mal was die Motorik angeht, die Bewegung angeht,das Heben von schweren Lasten und solche Sachen.
Diese Exoskelette gibt es ja schon. Die werden beiuns auf der Erde schon eingesetzt. Zum Beispiel
beim Militär, wenn Soldaten längere Märsche machenmüssen und schweres Gepäck auf dem Rücken haben.
Oder bei der Gepäckverteilung auf Flughäfenwird das auch schon eingesetzt. Das Problem
bei solchen Exoskeletten ist erstens, dass derAkku, also die Batterie, relativ schwer ist,
immer noch zu schwer ist und dass die Laufzeitdieses Akkus auch zu kurz ist. Das heißt, diese
Teile müssen ständig aufgeladen werden. Aber ineiner Galaxis, in der es möglich ist, in einem 30 cm
langen Griff die Energie zu speichern,
um ein Lichtschwert zu betreiben, da wird es auch
möglich sein, bessere Batterien herzustellen,um Darth Vader mit Energie zu versorgen.
Halten wir fest. Die Technik,die Darth Vader am Leben hält,
die ist durchaus realistisch dargestellt.
Vielleicht nicht in der passenden Größe undKomplexität.
Also nach unserem aktuellenStand der Technik, müsste der Anzug sehr,
sehr schwer sein und würde eine MengeEnergie verbrauchen. Aber in einer Galaxie
weit weit entfernt kann ich mir durchausvorstellen, dass das Ganze funktioniert.
An dieser Stelle geht großer Dank raus anLuke vom Kanal Nerdfactory, an Professor Zitt,
vielen Dank fürs Erleuchten. Dankeauch an „Stars of the Galaxy“,
die Ausstellung, in der wirdas Ganze hier machen durften.
Die Links zu all denen packeich Euch unten in die Infobox.
An dieser Stelle noch ein Shout-Out anflyingaround_ aus unserer Community.
Du hast nämlich in unserer Ant-Man-Folge alleunsere Mini-Sehenswürdigkeiten richtig erkannt.
Vergesst Ihr auf jeden Fall nichtauf abonnieren zu drücken und…
Hau auf die Glocke!
Dann können wir uns bald wieder
sehen. Möge die Macht mit euch sein!
(Also ich habe ja schon ein bisschen Puder draufaber musst Du eigentlich noch in die Maske?)
(Also „Ent-Vader“ wir gehen
heute Abend ins Schwimmbad,
oder wir trinken einen Vaderweißer zusammen.)
(Vader noch!)
(Was ist mit Dir?)
(Jetzt filmst Du oder was?)